I sit here with my companions my Chums
my pals son of obsession hello hello and
uh Matt gorley Now Matt I'm told that
you're a little loopy today because
you're on some kind of powerful
medication what's going on I mean look
at him
you've got a very different posture than
normal seriously what's happening what's
up Groove bones
yes Groove Bones the name I've always
wished I had uh well I found out I have
tennis elbow and so they put me on some
anti-inflammatories that making me feel
pretty good okay can you tell me exactly
what the medication is
indomethacin does that sound familiar
that was outlawed years ago
hey you're funny yeah what's tennis
elbow and I I'm sure everybody knows
what it is I I didn't know I mean I've
heard it but it's just I think it's an
inflammation of the tendons in your
elbow and do you play tennis no why
would you call it tennis elbow okay what
have you been doing what do you want me
to call it um collecting old
typewriter's elbow yes what did you have
you uh been over using that arm I
cleared everything out of our garage by
myself box after box and wife threw you
out huh yeah again okay well so you're
on these powerful anti-inflammatories
what are these side effects do you feel
drowsiness drowsiness yeah okay so I do
you do what you feel that okay are you
gonna be able to drive home no okay okay
well give it a shot could one of you
guys give me a ride I could easily call
you an Uber but part of me thinks we
need things to talk about on the podcast
well why don't you drive home in this
condition
and just see what happens the loopiest
I've been have I told you this I may
have mentioned this but the first time
that I had a procedure and they gave me
a Twilight drug oh yeah
mentioned that a few times okay but did
I tell you how um my wife had to come
pick me up she had to walk me home and I
just was a child I was a child I was on
this Twilight drug and this is in New
York and so we had to walk like 15
blocks and she was like holding my hand
and leading me back to the apartment
that's cute like I was a baby and then I
just looked at her at one point and I
said I want to go to McDonald's
like a kid would yeah and so she took me
to McDonald's and I was as happy as I've
been in my adult life I would love to go
to McDonald's yeah because there's
something about it was so Primal I just
wanted
comfort food and I went back to my
childhood love my wife she did a nice
thing she took me to McDonald's and she
said sit here and don't move I remember
that don't move
and I swear to God she put like you know
like a burger king crown on me or
something did she get you a Happy Meal I
don't think she got me a Happy Meal I
think she got me a quarter pounder but
she got me a shake you dip your chicken
mcnugs and your shake is that an
euphemism yeah you're a freak did you
put your balls in the shoes
well I did that
just be clear is all I'm asking you is
that a thing
that's a common thing it's called tea
bagging yeah tea bagging Grimace
um it's called the ultimate tea bag
himself yeah yeah his Grimace still used
do they still have the characters that
we grew up watching
like Hamburglar they're all gone yeah
remember there were some that actually
went away early on because there's mayor
mcchees and there's the police Burger
guy right but they got rid of them I
love those characters yeah and the fry
guys I know Ronald's gone but they got
rid of everybody Ronald's gone Ronald's
not gone well you don't see him no you
don't see him in uh commercials anymore
yeah when was the last time you saw
Ronald McDonald good question I saw him
at Costco the other day okay well maybe
you should hey man when you when you're
not as inflamed man hey man hey thanks
for being here chongs nice to have you
truth
I'll tell you the truth I'm happy to
tell you you know this is just an anti
inflammatory it you're not on LSD
this is just such a lightweight you're
such a lightweight it's incredible this
is taking me back to when we did the
summer s'mores and you had a little bit
of a drink and started trying to kiss me
on my left nipple
and I was like you literally have the
equivalent of a rum flavored cough drop
and now you've got your hand on my upper
thigh oh my God Joe who works here at
the show and is working in this very
room often Joe today asked me seriously
she said are you on Adderall because
she's so cool and she said she is she
said and she wasn't joking she said are
you on Adderall and I said no and she
said okay so what is it and I said no
this is because she was talking about
how energetic and talkative I am yeah
and I said this is just who I am and she
went okay okay she asked if I was on
Adderall now the reason she said I want
to try and be a little more like you and
I said because Joe is so cool she is so
cool and laid back and kind of
effortlessly like when you're like that
everyone thinks you're the coolest
person in the room and said Joe you
don't want to be like me I want to be
like you and I can't but she asked me if
I was on Adderall I would was shocked
when I found out your comedy comes from
a sober place
I thought like your writer's room was
just like you guys are all lighting up
joints and you're just like you know
you're pretty straight I'm like oh
that's coming from a real sober Place
well not a healthy place but a sober
Place yeah I know but you make perfect
you make perfect uh oh I'm sorry
um I think yeah I think Matt just fell
asleep she did not you're fine how long
we've been going well we've been going a
little while but anyway I think we uh
realized an important thing yeah which
is uh we all love different kinds of
fast food I'll go with Wendy's and that
you are a lightweight and that your
minutes from your heart stopping you
need to guess
I mean you are really looping out right
now did you just snort it out stuff from
your face you made me snot okay I made
you snot you manufactured the mucus and
maybe I said something that made you
expel it from your nose but I didn't
make you snot you you had it how long
does tennis elbow last I hope a long
time
oh my God this is a different man I
don't know about I'm enjoying it well I
want I want me some of this stuff I'm
gonna go to my doctor tonight to say
I've got tennis elbow you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna go out and buy a
brand new tennis racket it's going to
still have the price tag on it and I'll
go when I go I've got tennis elbow I
need the anti-inflammatory
oh doc hello
you'll say why are you holding that
racket it hasn't even been taken out of
the packaging yet
I was on the court I really uh had a
good game